[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en París un programa de radio
Francia internacional en colaboración
con la televisión Franz 24 en español en
la que como cada semana damos la palabra
a representantes de la política las
ciencias las artes la cultura y claro
está de la sociedad civil hoy vamos a
viajar a México al Estado de Sinaloa
ubicado en el noroeste de ese país
notablemente al municipio de Badiraguato
tristemente célebre por la presencia de
haber sido la cuna de varios de los
representantes del narcotráfico en
México saludamos a la doctora en
Antropología Abel Velázquez autora del
excelente libro Love selection
amaneció muerto violencia armada y
cultura de la amapola en México editado
por el cnrs bienvenida Adele Muchas
gracias con nosotros el libro que usted
presenta Es un fresco social podríamos
decir económico político de una región
marginal en México profundamente
asociada de una otra manera al mercado
mundial Y eso Gracias a la amapola el
libro que usted ha elaborado es una
forma de radiografía de cómo operan los
grupos de Cómo vive ese pedazo de la
sociedad es el hilo conductor usted
vivió ahí entre 2013 y en 2015 Cuáles
son los aspectos que hay que destacar de
la parte social y económica de ese
municipio célebre a nivel internacional
claro el punto para mí en un principio
era un poco deshacerse de toda esa fama
de ser cuna del narcotráfico base del
Cartel De Sinaloa y al contrario como
hacer una etnografía para ver cuál era
el cotidiano y al final de cuentas
valiera aguato es un municipio Serrano
con dificultades de acceso con muchas
dificultades económicas en la cual se ve
esa paradoja de ser a la vez muy
marginalizado y a la vez en el centro de
esta economía Mundial de la droga
Entonces mi trabajo se enfoca no en los
personajes que siempre
estuvimos mencionando en el cuando
estamos hablando de narcotráfico de
México es decir ni en los grandes
traficantes ni tampoco en el estado sino
en la gente común que trata de vivir en
este lugar es lo que usted llama Los
invisibles concretamente Cuáles son ese
tipo de personas de ese pedazo de la
sociedad mexicana
pues serían gente que han nacido en el
lugar y que pueden estar no sé por
ejemplo pueden tener una tienda en la
cabecera pueden ser empleado en los
servicios del ayuntamiento de la
presidencia municipal pero en la sierra
en la parte Serrana del municipio pues
mucha gente al final de cuenta para
sobrevivir se encuentran produciendo
Amapola antes de la crisis de la amapola
en el 2017 los decía usted es un
municipio muy marginal ciertamente un
que usted describe en su libro donde el
que desplazarse puede ser una cosa muy
arriesgada hay que tener cuidado Por qué
razón Claro porque el punto central de
la organización económica del lugar como
yo lo he podido estudiar es que todo
radica en el en el enclave en el ser
aislado Entonces el poder desplazarse es
un recurso a la vez central y muy
mal repartido es decir en el en el en el
lado de la de la organización de la
economía de la amapola los que acumulan
dinero son los que pueden transportar el
producto los pueden transformar pero
también para la gente común que vive ahí
pues desplazarse puede ser algo sencillo
si uno conoce el lugar donde donde va
donde los ranchos que va a cruzar Pero
puede ser muy difícil si hay un
conflicto entre dos gavillas de dos
ranchos
cercanas durante los dos años que duró
su investigación que estuvo ahí usted en
Badiraguato tuvo la oportunidad de
observar al detalle lo que era la
evolución de esa sociedad eso se refleja
en los seis capítulos que hacen parte
del libro al que hacemos referencia uno
de esos capítulos se llama estar allí y
lo que plantea es una pregunta que le
hizo una observación Mejor dicho que le
hizo un habitante de Badiraguato que
puede sorprender al público él le dijo
sabes por qué las tortugas viven 100
años y la respuesta cuál fue exactamente
porque no metes una nariz en asuntos
ajenos es decir en el caso de la
sociedad de Badiraguato Qué significa
eso quiere decir que hay una atención
central en para desenvolverse un lugar
donde hay tanto hay violencia por un
lado es esencial decisivo Tener
información sobre Qué es lo que está
pasando alrededor sobre cuál es el
equilibrio que estamos teniendo a la
hora entre varias redes o varios grupos
varias gavillas es necesario tener
información
cuando amaneció muerto más o menos saber
si este muerto va a ser un lo que llaman
un caso aislado o si ese muerto puede
ser un indicio de una de un período de
una temporada alta de violencia lo cual
de mayor violencia entonces muy
importante tener información pero a la
vez Buscar información puede ser muy
sospechoso porque no estamos en un lugar
donde mucha gente lo se lo representa
como si hubiera un cartel de un lado
como una organización criminal y luego
la gente que vive ahí pero pues es como
es una es la principal economía o casi
la principal Economía del lugar pues al
final de cuenta todos tenemos un
pariente o alguien que conocemos que
puede estar más o menos involucrado no
que es que sea parte de una organización
sino que de una forma pues la gente lo
mencionaría como anda mal o se metió en
algo entonces es difícil Buscar
información en Es peligroso Entonces
algo muy importante es hacer como si no
nos interesaría Y ese es ese dicho
porque la tortuga vive Cien años es un
es muy importante hacer como si todo eso
no nos interesaría no meterse en chisme
no preguntar cosas es muy son muy
escasas en las preguntas directas es
decir claro nunca se puede o sea yo
nunca he escuchado en mi trabajo de
campo alguien que dijera Quién mató a
fulano pero fuera de este caso un poco
extremo de una pregunta claramente
sensible pues las preguntas así directas
son muy raras hay un elemento central
que es que toda la población sin
excepción tiene temor a algo y ese algo
es el ejército mexicano el hecho que se
sepa que va a llegar el ejército que van
a
arribar los soldados plantea un
desajuste precisamente a todos los
niveles explícanos un poco eso A usted
le tocó precisamente hacer frente a esa
situación Desde la distancia pero ahí
explíquenos esa situación sí Al final el
territorio está hay una un cuartel
militar en la cabecera pero ahí también
cuarteles en la sierra y luego están las
rondas de los soldados que son
temporarias son rotaciones entonces a la
vez los habitantes que yo he podido
conocer están muy acostumbrados a ver
soldados porque están en el paisaje
social ahí están pero a la vez en
particular cuando estamos en la sierra
donde mucha gente necesita cultivar
Amapola que su que su parcela su siembra
crezca que la pueda cosechar el la
llegada de los soldados implica mucha
incertidumbre porque los soldados pueden
destruir Las parcelas las pueden quemar
o tumbar o también les pueden echar
defoliante productos químicos pero
también se pueden meter a las casas
entonces en los ranchos donde Pues hay
una
un interconocimiento la gente se conoce
están checando cuando llegan los
soldados pues implica una nueva
vigilancia hay que estar más atento a
todo para protegerse de la represión
militar Y hay un tríptico que se puede
decir ahí en ese caso que es la
intimidación la represión y la
corrupción Sí hay un es exactamente este
tríptico del punto de vista de los de
las personas con las cuales Yo trabajé
que son familias de productores Ellos
están enfrente sin ayuda de la O sea
están confrontados directamente por la
extorsión militar los soldados Pueden
decir hemos ubicado tal parcela pero no
la vamos a tumbar si me das 2000 pesos
entonces tienen que lidiar con un
cálculo súper difícil de saber porque
ese esos soldados que le pueden decir
que pesos no le van a tumbar las flores
luego se va y luego viene otro y el otro
igual y no es lo mismo o pide lo mismo o
lo destruye Y entonces el productor ya
no puede cosechar y los 2000 pesos que
adelantó pues ya es están perdidos
lidiar con los soldados es un dilema
lidiar con otro tipo de personaje que se
llama usted llama Los Pesados o que la
población llama Los Pesados también
representa un dilema Quiénes son esos
pesados esos pesados es la gente que lo
dice el pesado de tal lugar así lo
llaman el pesado sería en esa
organización económica el que tiene los
medios de transporte y de transformación
entonces gracias a acuerdos con la
jerarquía militar no el pesado no está
sujeto a esa ese acoso militar del que
viven los demás pobladores Entonces el
pesado es el que puede transformar La
goma en heroína es el que puede
transportar la mercancía Y es el acumula
mucho dinero entonces el que tiene mucho
poder económico en un rancho dado o en
un o en una serie de rancho es el que
puede hacer fiestas y es el que compra
La cosecha de sus vecinos Entonces el
pesado es una figura extraña a la vez es
un protector de alguna forma y es un es
el que permite que se venda La cosecha
económicamente es un personaje
importante para la supervivencia del de
los ranchos pero a la vez pues hay mucho
temor O sea no es como si fuera tampoco
una relación así de tú a tú en el
sentido de que al final los productores
no tienen de otra que venderle a él
porque ellos no pueden mover su goma no
tienen de otras que pedirle protección a
él el contexto de violencia hace que la
protección la posibilidad misma de dar
protección es algo central que le da un
poder
que habría que matizar en este sentido y
hablando de protección hay un elemento
que para mí llamó mucho mi atención que
tiene que ver en un microcosmos en el
que el hombre es dominante y sobre todo
hombre violento puede ser dominante el
papel de la mujer hay una frase que le
dijeron a usted si alguien si un hombre
si le gustas a un hombre no pienses que
te va a pedir te va a robar que es el
primer paso a un secuestro probablemente
a la violencia la violación con todas
las implicaciones que esto tiene
socialmente para la mujer y para la
familia de la mujer sí es un caso a la
vez extremo la posibilidad de robarse o
sea de secuestrar a una mujer y de
obligar a que se fuera a vivir con uno
pero también está anclado en lo que en
México se llama el robo de mujer que es
una expresión que puede
significar un secuestro armado como en
Casos que he podido documentar en mi
trabajo de campo pero también como algo
parecido a la fuga del novio Entonces
está
la vida que conocen las mujeres en Valle
iraguato está un poco a la función entre
el
patriarcalismo y el machismo más general
en la sociedad mexicana y la posibilidad
de la violencia que está muy presente el
contexto de violencia que hace como bien
dijo que la protección es una necesidad
imperiosa pues muchísimas gracias por
habernos acompañado en esta escala en
París no me queda sino agradecerle una
breve Purísima brevemente sus libros
será publicado en español muy brevemente
pues bienvenido esperamos rápidamente
posible gracias Abel Velázquez doctora
de antropología por estar con nosotros
autora del libro un muerto al Alba del
cnrs ya ustedes les damos una nueva cita
aquí la próxima semana en otra escala en
París gracias por su presencia
[Música]
[Aplausos]